il en direct dans ce gîte et gérard
investir chercheur associé à la fée mot
la fondation d'études pour le
moyen-orient bonjour merci de répondre à
nos questions avant d'évoquer ce partage
de pouvoir un mot sur cette nouvelle
attaque ce matin avec le bilan qui
grimpe à cette mort en maintenant
attaquer qui intervient en pleine
recrudescence des violences malgré un
accord fin février entre talibans et
états unis qui prévoit le départ de
toutes les troupes étrangères du pays
d'ici à mi 2009 21 écoutez déjà c'est
une étape importante qui vient d'être
franchie mais ce n'est pas un accord
historique
les deux protagonistes le président
ghani et abdullah abdullah ont été
respectivement lin président et notre
premier ministre du président du
président donc il y à une séparation de
leurs relations et un conflit lié à la
dernière élection présidentielle et donc
tous les deux s'étant autoproclamé
président au début du mois de mars trois
jours après l'accord entre les usa les
talibans dans qu' il était important
pour la politique américaine de mettre
un petit peu d'ordre dans cette
situation là les etats unis ont décidé
de suspendre un milliard de dollars dead
à l'afghanistan et je pense que cette
incitation négative à aider à la
conclusion de cet accord de la
cordillère donc c'est un accord
important parce que il réunit deux
opposants politiques récents
deuxièmement il permet de réunir la
mosaïque tribales et ethniques afghane
dans la mesure où tous les deux sont
détenus des deux tribus différentes
troisièmement il y à l'arrivée aussi du
maréchal a nouvellement nommé rashid
dostum qui était un ancien allié du
président un allié récent d'abdullah
abdullah
donc voilà l'ensemble des importants
participant au pouvoir afghan se sont
réunis autour de cet accord et quelle
marge de manoeuvre pour cette alliance
face aux talibans et au groupe etat
islamique
alors là voilà on est au coeur du
problème
la radicalité pour pas dire la
sauvagerie de l'état islamique que pose
quand même un problème politique à la au
talibans parce que ils ont trouvé plus
radicaux et plus extrémiste que en
conséquence de quoi ils sont légèrement
hors centre et si je puis dire en termes
de géométrie politique afghane donc ils
ont à prendre en considération cette
rivalité qui peut être aussi une
alliance possible donc entre talibans et
à islamique donc ça c'est un choix très
important que les talibans vont avoir à
mener dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent justement l'attaqué qui a eu
lieu ce matin par revendiquée encore est
ce qu'elle a un lien avec avec ce qui
s'est passé hier ce partage de pouvoir
est ce qu'on peut y voir les taliban ou
le groupe etat islamique
il y a les attentats portent uniquement
toutes les semaines peut pas dire tous
les jours en afghanistan donc c'est
vraiment très difficile de démêler cet
écheveau là il y a eu au lendemain de la
taille de l'état islamique et la
déclaration du président qu'il allait
s'attaquer lui même a à l'ensemble des
mouvements et bien les des talibans
avaient des claques déclencher une
attaque contre un poste de police dont
24 heures après voyez vous donc tout est
vraiment dans une grande mobilité
d'actions terroristes et mais les
talibans vont avoir un rôle important à
jouer
de même que les états unis car
n'oublions pas que l'envoyé spécial du
département d'état américain
khalilzad un est un homme d'origine
afghane il est né en afghanistan il ya
une centaine d'années
il a fait ses études c'est un citoyen
américain mais il d'origine afghane donc
il a un rôle très important à jouer dont
la négociation comme il l'a prouvé déjà
quelle réaction de la part de la
communauté internationale et des états
unis après ce partage de
de pouvoir hier est ce que la communauté
internationale a déjà réagi ou est ce
qu'elle va réagir et si vous comment ça
se passe
c'est plus une réunion qu'un partage
alors bien sûr il ya partage mais il y a
avant tout une réunion de ces deux
dirigeants n'est ce pas c'est ça qui est
c'est le point positif qu'il faut
absolument garder en tête et maintenant
le abdullah abdullah que nous voyons à
l'écran là maintenant à un rôle
important en tant que responsable de la
commission de réconciliation nationale
csu en partie sur ses épaules que vont
reposer et bien les dialogue à venir
entre le pouvoir afghan et les talibans
merci gérard vespière d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur associé à la fema la fondation
pour le moyen-orient
merci à vous